chuyển thống 8.4 dừng và trường thành của ngay sống dục,
hàng định quyết tâm đổi mới phương pháp sĩ học,
tạo mua trường học tập sáng tạo, thân thiệt,
xuống học sinh danh liệt, trường thành.
Các con cũng rất là phần khởi,
được thử, một cái haisa xy phuyến tại chiếc tiếp từ các nhà nước.
Các bật ui cũng đã không vừa vừa vừa,
và các các bật ui cũng rất phần khởi khổ hồi.
Bụng lỏ lòng một cái kỷ liệm và người tạm miếng năm.
Hành lập, hành lập dục, gần nát.
Chúng lức học không khí khai sạm chực tiến hiện liên gió nét.
Các em nhỏ hồi lên nắn, chăm chủ theo dõi từ khi anh
từng lời phát biểu phát sà từ mạnh hình.
Sự hôn diên tập chú ấy đã biến bùi học lợi tiên thành một tránh nghiệp đặt biệt.
Dú các em cảm giận được mình đang cùng hàng chiệu vãnh nhỏ trên cả nước.
Đóng trang rất học mới.
Còn nay là một ngày, hai dạm đặt biệt.
Cô chó, chúng tôi rất là buối mân phấn khởi.
Đặc biệt là được khai sạm chực tiến.
Được mình thấy các em điện đạo đẹp.
Cô và tròn chúng tôi rất là buối mân.
Chúng khi đó, tại trường chung học cơ sơ, chung học phụ thông lệ quy đôn.
Lế khai sạm giến, tại trường chồng sau và lế tại sinh chương.
Thầy và trồng cũng chờ về lấp để kết lủ chực tiến.
Đối với năm ngoặc này, bên cạnh, kế lế khai sạm rất đặc biệt.
Nhân khi niệm tảm, lế khi niệm tảm, nằm ngay tảy là bộ phức ra gạo rộng.
Chúng ta đều biết là năm năm chúng ta rất đất nước của chúng ta mới tổ chức khảnh không.
Lế khi niệm tảm, ngay khách mạng thẳng và khách mùng hai thạy chiến.
Và đây cũng là cái móc sòn để bước vào rất nước, bước vào một cái dài rộng mới.
Đó là dài rộng khi nguyên vâng mình của nhân tộc.
Học sinh các khối cấp hai chăm chú lắng nghe thông đẹp của lãnh đạo đàn, nhà nước,
vây nhận những định hướng, kì phòng cho thế hệ chạy trong năm học mới.
Nen giao dục, cần tiến phòng bởi bối trong từ rí phương pháp bỏ trị.
Sây dịch bỏ vụ nhả giáo vừa của chi thức vừa của đạo nước và khách phòng cũng viem.
Các thầy của giáo phở là tấm dinh sáng, ngừng cặm tứng cho học trò.
Các tròo học sinh xin viên phẩy nui dữ, gí lớn khách phòng lớn,
không tập vào giai luyện để trở thành công sinh tọn cầu tình bước khỏi nhập trở mực của thế,
như vương dữ bản thác của tâm hồn vừa làm.
Còn khi nóm nước trong ánh nóc học trò tiêu học, sử chứng trà của học sinh xù học,
cùng nguyên tinh của các thầy của giáo đã làm nên một lễ khais sàng vừa trang nghiêm vừa ấm thấp.
Tự hai đềm chương, nếu vui khais sàng hôm nay đã làm toa,
mở ra một lâm học mới với nhiều khách phòng và ký phòng.